One of the things you want to do with
the conception,
like compassionate as you actually want
to start thinking about it like a
psychologist or like a scientist,
because compassion is actually definable
and it.
I think the easiest way to approach it
is to think about it in big five terms
because it.
It maps onto agreeableness and
especially you can break agreeableness
down into compassion and politeness and
the liberal types,
especially the social justice types are
way higher in compassion.
It's actually their fundamental
characteristic and you might think,
well,
compassion is is a virtue.
It's like,
yes,
it is average you,
but any unit,
dimensional virtue immediately becomes a
vice because real virtue is the
intermingling of a number of virtues and
their and their integration into a
functional identity that can be
expressed socially and compassion.
Passion is great if you happen to be the
entity towards which it is directive,
but compassion tends to divide the world
into a crying children and predatory
snakes.
Right?
And so if you're a crying child,
hey,
great man,
but if you happen to be identified as
one of the predatory snakes,
you better look the hell out.
And so,
you know,
compassionate is what the mother,
grizzly bear feels for her cubs when she
eats you because you've got in the way.
Right?
Exactly.
So we don't want to be thinking for a
second that compassion isn't a,
uh,
a virtue that could lead to violence
because it certainly can't.
And the other problem with compassion,
this is why we have conscientiousness,
right?
There's five canonical personality
dimensions.
Agreeableness is pretty good if you're
dealing,
again,
in akin system,
you want to distribute resources
equally,
for example,
among your children,
because you want all of them to have not
only the same chance you even walk them
roughly to have the same outcome,
a good one,
but the problem is you can't extend that
moral network to larger groups.
Not as far as I can tell.
You need conscientiousness,
which is a much colder virtue.
And it's also a virtue that's much more
concerned with larger structures over
the longer period of time.
So,
and you can take about conscientiousness
is a form of compassion to.
It's a strange form.
It's like straighten the hell out and
work hard and your life will go well.
It's like,
I don't care how your feelings,
how you feel about that right now.
And like someone who's cold low in
agreeableness and high in
conscientiousness,
that's what they'll tell you every time.
Don't,
don't come whining to me.
I don't care about your hurt feelings.
Do Your Goddamn job.
Are you going to be out on the street?
It's like,
oh,
that person's being really hard on me.
It's like not necessarily.
They might have your long term best
interest in mind and you're fortunate if
you come across someone who's like not
too radically disagreeable but
moderately disagreeable and high in
conscientiousness because the whip you
into shape.
And that's really helpful.
I mean you,
you'll admire people like that.
You won't be able to help it,
you know,
and you think,
oh wow,
this person's going to be good
inflammation even though you know,
you feel like a slug after you after
they've taken you apart.
So.
Okay,
so that's the compassion issue.
It's like you can't just transform that
into a political stance and I think part
of what we're seeing is actually the
rise of a form of female
totalitarianism,
so we have no idea what totalitarianism
would be like if women ran it because
that's never happened before in the
history of the planet and so we've
introduced women into the political
sphere radically over the last 50 years.
We have no idea what the consequences of
that is going to be,
but we do know from our research,
which is preliminary,
that agreeableness really predicts
political correctness,
but female gender predicts over and
above the personality trait and that's
something we found very rarely in our
research.
Usually the sex differences are wiped
out by the personality differences,
but not in this particular case.
And then you know,
women are getting married later and
they're having children much later and
they're having fewer of them and so you
also have to wonder what their feminine
orientation is doing with itself in the
interim.
Roughly speaking,
and a lot of it's being expressed as
political opinion,
like in fair enough.
You know,
that's,
that's fine,
but it's not fine.
When it starts to shut down discussion.